et bien Nina les réactions sont
partagées il y a d'un côté le sentiment
très fort d'attachement à l'Ukraine et
de l'autre des sympathies prorus hier
nous avons assisté à une grande
manifestation de sur le centre-ville
avec quelques centaines de personnes
d'opposant Vladimir Poutine notamment
qui réagissait à son discours disant que
l'Ukraine était un état fantoche à ses
allégations les manifestants ont crié
dans la ville gloire à l'Ukraine et
répéter que l'Ukraine était état était
un État indépendant et qu'il avait droit
aussi à sa souveraineté de l'autre côté
nous avons aussi parlé à des à des
personnes vivant ici qui avait aussi qui
affiché
publiquement leur sympathie prorus ils
accueillaient plutôt avec bienveillance
les récents discours de Vladimir Poutine
et parmi eux il y a aussi ceux pour qui
se les déclarations de Vladimir Poutine
en fait sont bien accueillis car elle
permettrait selon eux de mettre fin à un
conflit Harvey qui dure depuis
maintenant 8 ans je précise que dans la
ville pour l'instant il y a rien à
signaler il n'y a pas de mouvement de
panique beaucoup gens ont peur
évidemment de voir des des troupes
russes arriver dans la ville mais pour
l'instant les gens préfèrent temporiser
ils attendent de voir comment les
prochains jours vont évoluer il n'est
pas question pour eux de partir et même
pour certains nous ont-ils dit il
n'avait nulle part où aller même si les
Russes devaient arriver ici
Julien bonjour Pourquoi Mario Paul
a-t-elle une position 6 stratégique dans
ce conflit
et bien Mario Paul c'est déjà la plus
grande ville qui se trouve à l'est de
l'Ukraine sous contrôle du gouvernement
du Kiev elle est composée d'environ 450
000 habitants et vous pouvez peut-être
le voir derrière moi à l'abri d'un très
grand port industriel c'est un poumon
économique c'est aussi un symbole pour
Kiev qui est ne veut surtout pas perdre
cette ville puisque cette ce port est
situé sur la mer d'azoff et on sait que
Moscou a des velléités sur cette zone
très stratégique et d'après plusieurs
d'après plusieurs analystes et bien
cette zone Moscou a les yeux rivés sur
Mario Paul car si vous regardez sur une
carte à l'est de la ville nous sommes à
20 km de la ligne de front environ à
l'est de la ville se trouve donc les
régions séparatistes du Dombas c'est
plus au sud se trouve la crinée que la
Moscou avait annexé en 2014 l'idée selon
ses années l'idée de Moscou l'un des
scénarios de Moscou selon ses analystes
et bien ce serait de relier la Crimée à
le Dombasle via Mario Paul
ce scénario commencerait à se mettre en
place toujours ses analystes surtout
après les déclarations hier de Vladimir
Poutine indiquant qu'il reconnaissait
donc l'indépendance des deux régions
séparatistes de Logan et de donuts selon
les frontières indiquées dans leur
constitution et dans sa constitution les
frontières inclut notamment la ville de
Mario Paul merci Julien en direct de
Mario Paul et on va continuer à
s'intéresser aux